Evos ground floor will be two stories
high to make room for street-level
retail stores the third floor will hold
25 condo units which means a lot more
wiring for things like speaker cables
and floor receptacles to manage this
extra work
Ron reader has come aboard as deck
Foreman make sure that what's on these
plants is getting in I mean it's very
easy to get confused out there and
probably thought a few things already
this morning so one mistake and then you
lost your run so you got to be dead on
five foot three East the center
challenge number one is deciphering the
plans this floor alone requires four
sets of electrical drawings to
complicate things even more the drawings
get updated weekly with last-minute
changes by the architects that line has
changed
because that's where they told me it was
and then after I started looking at it
I'm like no I asked the other day and
how far is the debt going they said
three feet pastel
it's actually 3 feet past and another
problem is that many of the chalk layout
marks they made yesterday got washed off
to keep this from happening again they
use a can of spray fixer
boss Bob Mott arrives to double-check
their work
he walls like right here right on the
stud just somewhere over on to the side
so we can get them down past the the
ductwork that goes all through here he
knows that once everything gets buried
in concrete going back will be a
nightmare
we come up and walk the deck a couple of
times before they even set the rebar
down it's not his name on the job it's
my name on the job Bob also needs to
make sure his crew stays in sync with
the ever-changing plans of mine they
don't want us to put anything in the
retail area so we're gonna have to run
that different so I pulled the Box up
this this don't put it in don't put it
in don't put it in down below this is
retail I can't run